stell dir vor du müsstest von a nach b
kommen und hat dafür zwei möglichkeiten
die beiden reisearten sind aber
unterschiedlich gefährlich eine kostet
jährlich 1,3 millionen menschen das
leben die andere nur
287 welche würdest du wählen nun ihr
könnt es euch wahrscheinlich denken weil
wir die frage sonst nicht so formuliert
hätten aber die meisten menschen wählen
tatsächlich die variante bei der
jährlich 13 millionen menschen umkommen
warum unser gehirn risiken häufig falsch
einschätzt wie vor den komplett falschen
dingen angst haben und was man dagegen
tun kann das erfährst du in diesem video
[Musik]
der sponsor unseres heutigen videos ist
man jemand ganz anderes den wir hier
noch gar nicht hatten nämlich vorsichtig
die unter anderem eine ganz neue art von
kaffee anbieten aber da ich selber nicht
wirklich viel kaffee trinken übergebe
ich euch für dieses sponsoren segment an
den größten kaffeetrinker und genießer
den ich persönlich kenne nämlich unseren
postproduction supervisor marian
vielleicht denkt ihr euch ok und kaffee
was ein jedes produkt des bundes auf
diesem kanal ja ja ich auch recht mit
andererseits gibt aber auch erschreckend
viele leute wie mich zum beispiel bei
denen so eine heiße
lebens energie spendende tasse boden
muss einfach zu einem erfolgreichen
start in den tag gehört aber auch das
immer so gut ist in diesem ganzen
kaffeekonsum da scheinen sich ja auch
die geister und ich sag mal so boden aus
nicaragua oder was sind jetzt auch nicht
dass aller nachhaltigste lebensmittel
und da kommt dieser kaffee von frostig
magic ins spiel das ist kaffeepulver
aber dem sind zwei arten von pilzen
beigemischt klingt erstmal merkwürdig in
der praxis muss man allerdings sagen
schmecken sollte erstmal gar nichts von
schmeckt angenehm aromatisch schon mit
einer eigenen note dafür haben einmal
diese sogenannten functional maschens
die da drin sind wird einiger studien
durchaus vorteile unterstützung des
immunsystems der wanderung steigerung
der produktivität und man hat auch nicht
so schnell mittags tief wie das manchmal
bei normalen café des falles immer dann
heilen wenn der körper so sagt
proportionen in diesem café so ungefähr
500 milligramm von diesen pilzen drin
und das macht auch so einer schönen
tasse kaffee ein regelrechtes super food
drink
dieser kaffee ist dabei natürlich auch
komplett legal bio fairtrade und
vorsichtig machen nicht nur kaffee
sondern auch so was wie kakao protein
pulver sogar kosmetik alles möglichst
nachhaltig und das war mir und uns
eigentlich besonders wichtig und dieses
produkt hier empfehlen zu können
also erfüllt dieser kaffee die
satisfaktion espressobohnen unter
größter anstrengungen durch deine
hipster wind in studien vom flohmarkt zu
jagen vielleicht nicht aber jetzt will
ich die satisfaktion der gewissheit dass
hier mit so etwas komisch und die café
eurem körper und dem planeten erde was
gutes tun könnt absolut am ende also mit
dem link unten in der video beschreibung
oder unserem coach doktor watson beim
checkout bekommt ihr bis zu 10% im
frostig magic shop und auch auf der
webseite habt ihr super viel
hintergrundmaterial um mit der
wissenschaft hinter dem ganzen noch mal
ganz in ruhe beschäftigen zu können
apropos wissenschaft
ich bin durch hier das klingt
tatsächlich ziemlich gut vielleicht
werde ich jetzt auch noch zum
kaffeetrinken gerade in der jetzigen
zeit müssen wir ständig risiken
einschätzen sehen wir unsere großeltern
fahren wir mit den öffentlichen
verkehrsmitteln lassen wir uns impfen
und auch wenn wir glauben wir haben gute
gründe für unsere entscheidung leider
ist unser gehirn ziemlich schlecht darin
risiken gegeneinander abzuwägen nehmen
wir zum beispiel einmal die verkehrswege
vom anfang 1,3 millionen menschen kommen
im schnitt jährlich im straßenverkehr um
im flugverkehr sind es hingegen 2009 10
nur
287 menschen gewesen trotzdem fühlst du
dich wahrscheinlich im auto sicherer als
im flugzeug das gleiche gilt für alle
möglichen szenarien vor welchem tier
hast du zum beispiel mehr ein ist vor
einer mücke oder vor einem hai durch
einen infektiösen mückenstich sterben
jedes jahr schätzungsweise
850.000 menschen damit ist die mücke
tatsächlich das gefährlichste tier der
welt doch wahrscheinlich fürchten sich
die meisten von euch er vor heim obwohl
die im schnitt nur zehn menschen pro
jahr töten solche fehleinschätzungen von
risiken sind nicht nur gefährlich für
den einzelnen sie können auch eine ganze
gesellschaft erfassen und so zb die
politik eines landes verändern die in
deutschland zum beispiel passiert beim
atomausstieg kurz nach dem
reaktorunglück in fukushima trat angela
merkel vor die presse und verkündete wir
werden schrittweise bis ende 2022
vollständig auf die kernenergie
verzichten und das obwohl die
bundesregierung erst wenige monate zuvor
beschlossen hatte die laufzeit einige
atomkraftwerke zu verlängern woher kam
der plötzliche sinneswandel
natürlich trugen verschiedene gründe
dazu bei und man kann den atomausstieg
jetzt gut oder schlecht finden das kann
und will ich jetzt die gerade gar nicht
debattieren bitte hört auf zu tippen
darum geht's eigentlich gerade gar nicht
aber der plötzliche atomausstieg ist ein
paradebeispiel dafür wie eine
fehleinschätzung von risiken die politik
eines gesamten landes beeinflussen kann
denn nach dem reaktorunglück war der
druck der bevölkerung auf die
bundesregierung riesig da gab es
natürlich zum einen die umweltschützer
die aus der atomkraft raus wollten aber
da gab es auch wahnsinnig viele menschen
die angst hatten dass solch eine
atomkatastrophe
auch in deutschland passieren könnte
plötzlich gab es überall jod tabletten
gegen atomstrahlung zu kaufen schon
selbst die baumärkte boten geigerzähler
an dabei war diese angst eine klassische
risiko fehleinschätzung der energy staff
prinz der die toten pro erzeugter
kilowattstunde energie angibt beziffert
wie gefährlich eine energiequelle ist er
wird von der weltgesundheitsorganisation
dem center for disease control der
national academy of science und anderen
instituten herausgegeben und beinhaltet
sowohl die toten beim abbau der
ressourcen als auch die toten durch die
direkte energiegewinnung also zum
beispiel durch reaktorunfälle und das
ergebnis des energy der prinz ist
eindeutig durch kohlestrom sterben zum
beispiel etwa 100.000 menschen pro
kilowattstunde durch atomstrom 90 damit
ist es wenn man sich die toten anschaut
die risiko ärmste energieerzeugung
überhaupt und durch den atomausstieg
hängt deutschland nun noch stärker von
der kohleverbrennung ab die vor allem
durch luftverschmutzung für insgesamt
wesentlich mehr todesfälle aber auch für
mehr krankheiten sorgt doch wie kommt es
dass wir menschen risiken so schlecht
einschätzen können und was kann man
dagegen tun der grund für diese
fehleinschätzung liegt überraschung in
der funktionsweise unseres gehirns denn
wie hoch wie ein risiko einschätzen
hängt vor allem von drei faktoren ab der
erste ist wie hoch wird die
wahrscheinlichkeit einschätzen dass uns
die gefahr überhaupt betrifft der zweite
ist unsere vermutung wie stark wir
betroffen wären wenn uns die gefahr
tatsächlich trifft zum beispiel mit den
verkehrsmitteln wäre das also die hoch
wie die wahrscheinlichkeit einschätzen
dass das flugzeug in dem wir sitzen
abstürzt und wie schlimm das für uns
wäre
achtung dabei geht es nicht darum wie
groß die gefahr wirklich ist nur darum
wie groß wir sie wahrnehmen
aber dazu später mehr und dann gibt es
noch einen dritten faktor über den wir
seltener bewusst nachdenken die
sogenannte selbstwirksamkeit die gibt an
wie sehr wir glauben dass wir uns vor
der gefahr schützen können denn wenn wir
das gefühl haben nichts gegen eine
gefahr tun zu können dann kann es leicht
passieren dass unser gehirn sie einfach
ignoriert um zu verhindern dass wir in
lähmende angst versinken übrigens eine
klassische ursache für
verschwörungstheorien wie wir in diesem
video hier zeigen doch was genau
beeinflusst nun wie wir diese drei
faktoren einschätzen können dafür gibt
es vor allem drei zentrale
psychologische mechanismen
natürlich gibt es noch viel viel mehr
aber wir konzentrieren uns jetzt mal auf
die wichtigsten denn er hat
wahrscheinlich keine zeit für ein ganzes
psychologie studium oder ein phänomen
ist bekannt als verfügbarkeit heuristik
es besagt dass wir das vorkommen einer
gefahr umso wahrscheinlicher einschätzen
je leichter uns ein beispiel für sie ein
feld das lässt sich gut an den
transportmitteln erklären wie häufig
wird in den nationalen medien darüber
berichtet wenn ein flugzeug abstürzt
quasi jedes mal ist auch eine ziemlich
große news und wie häufig steht ein
autounfall auf der titelseite nicht so
oft zusätzlich bleiben spektakuläre
flugzeugabstürze stärker in erinnerung
als alltägliche autounfälle ihr könnt
euch also leichter an beispiele für
flugzeugabstürze erinnern und somit
denkt euer gehirn dass sie
dementsprechend auch proportional
häufiger vorkommen dabei gab es
tatsächlich bei nur 23 von 47 millionen
flügen in 2009 10 einen unfall das
tatsächliche risiko ist also
verschwindend gering eng damit verbunden
ist der sogenannte bestätigungs fehler
oder auch besser bekannt als
konfirmation bei ist er beschreibt das
phänomen dass wir eher die dinge
wahrnehmen die unsere risikowahrnehmung
bestätigen jemand der angst vorm fliegen
hat wird jeden flugzeugabsturz als
bestätigung wahrnehmen dass seine angst
berechtigt ist die 46 millionen
999 1977 anderen flügel die alle ohne
unfall verliefen wird der stattdessen
kaum wahrnehmen oder sogar ausblenden
beide psychologischen mechanismen werden
befeuert vom sogenannten frame also
davon wie uns ein risiko präsentiert
wird und das lässt sich leider wie soll
es anders sein an der bild gut zeigen
hier ist eine schlagzeile über
hai-attacken was fällt euch dabei ein
wahrscheinlich verrückte haie und kratzt
seit 1934 gab es nicht mehr so viele
tote da wird man wahrscheinlich jetzt
liegen wir nach australien zum surfen
gehen oder vor meinem inneren auge tun
sich bei dieser überschrift berge von
leichen am strand alle verstümmelt durch
hai biss aber erst weiter unten im
artikel steht dass es im gesamten jahr
2020 insgesamt acht tote durch
haiangriffe gab also nicht so viele was
für konsequenzen das streaming haben
kann zeigt ein experiment aus der
psychologie den versuchsteilnehmern
wurde gesagt dass sie eine tödliche
leberkrankheit haben und nun entscheiden
müssen ob sie eine operation an sich
durchführen lassen würden der einen
hälfte wurde gesagt dass die
wahrscheinlichkeit bei der op zu sterben
bei 90 prozent liegt der anderen hälfte
wurde gesagt dass die wahrscheinlichkeit
die op zu überleben bei zehn prozent
liegt also im prinzip haben beide
gruppen die genau gleiche informationen
bekommen nur wurde sie anders
präsentiert aber das hat den
entscheidenden unterschied gemacht von
der gruppe denen die
sterbewahrscheinlichkeit genannt wurde
wählten 28 prozent die op wohingegen
sich 46 prozent für die op entschieden
haben als ihnen die
überlebenswahrscheinlichkeit genannt
wurde fazit die meisten von uns sind
also nicht nur generell schlecht im
statistik sondern wir lassen uns auch
stark dadurch beeinflussen wie sie uns
präsentiert wird zum glück sind wir
dagegen nicht ganz machtlos aber dazu
später mehr meistens haben wir nicht nur
ein risiko vor uns sondern müssen
verschiedene risiken gegeneinander
abwägen und dann stellt sich die große
frage welches risiko ist das kleinere
übel
was wollen wir mehr schützen ein
beispiel paul könnte mit dem zug zur
arbeit fahren anstatt mit seinem auto
denn mit diesem befeuert er den
klimawandel eine der größten gefahren
der die menschheit ausgesetzt ist also
ein großes risiko doch paul hat versucht
mit der bahn zu pendeln das problem war
nur er kam ständig zu spät zur arbeit
weil sein zug verspätung hat sein sein
chef hat ihm schon mit konsequenzen
gedroht und das risiko seinen job zu
verlieren möchte paul nicht eingehen den
klimawandel zu befeuern ist für ihn
persönlich das kleinere übel es geht für
paul also nicht nur darum was objektiv
betrachtet das größere risiko ist
sondern darum was ihm mehr wert ist für
ihn ist sein job also mehr wert als das
klima zu schützen und das bringt uns zu
einem sehr wichtigen punkt der teil der
lösung ist wenn wir wollen dass menschen
weniger risiken eingehen müssen wir erst
verstehen warum sie ein risiko eingehen
viele risiken gehen wir schlichtweg ein
weil uns etwas anderes wichtiger ist
wenn wir also wollen dass paul das klima
schützt dann müssen wir ihm eine lösung
für sein wichtigeres risiko bieten
nämlich dass er ohne auto zu spät zur
arbeit kommt das ist besonders wichtig
wenn es um risiken geht die die ganze
gesellschaft betreffen denn häufig ist
für die gesellschaft ein anderes risiko
wichtiger als für den einzelnen dieses
problem ist bekannt als tragödie des
allgemeinen gut einfach ausgedrückt
bedeutet das dass für paul seinen job
mehr wert ist während für die
gesellschaft der klimawandel das viel
größere risiko ist paul tut also was für
ihn den größten nutzen hat und die
gesellschaft als kollektiv muss dafür
zahlen und wenn das alles so machen dann
haben wir nun ja klimawandel
[Musik]
okay was können wir also dagegen tun was
können wir machen damit unser gehirn
nicht ständig falsche risiko
entscheidungen trifft wenn wir abwägen
wie groß ein risiko tatsächlich ist dann
sollten wir vor allem versuchen uns so
objektiv wie möglich zu informieren
besonders hilft es wenn du dir eine
frage stellt warum will ich mich so
entscheiden warum habe ich vor etwas
angst das verhindert zwar nicht dass
dein gehirn intuitiv risiken falsch
einschätzt aber wir können es so
bemerken und gegebenenfalls aktiv
korrigieren gegensteuern zusätzlich
müssen wir möglichst klar wissen was wir
tun können um uns zu schützen das ist
zum beispiel etwas das in der
kommunikation über den klimawandel
häufig noch viel co2 reduzieren ist zwar
eindeutig sagt dem einzelnen aber nicht
was konkret er oder sie tun kann oder
wenn wir die kurzschlüsse unseres
gehirns vermeiden wollen können wir
menschen menschen also unauffällig
anstupsen damit sie das richtige tun ein
berühmtes beispiel dafür sind fuß tapsen
vor dem aufzug die zur treppe führen
damit menschen sich mehr bewegen oder
frisches obst auf dem tisch wären
süßigkeiten weit oben irgendwo im regal
versteckt sind so oder so müssen wir
aber zuerst verstehen warum wir menschen
risiken falsch wahrnehmen oder bewusst
eingehen um passende lösungen anzubieten
und da können wir bei uns selber
wahrscheinlich am besten anfangen er
kennt ihr diese psychologischen
mechanismen bei euch auch wenn ihr
risiko entscheidungen trefft und habt
ihr schon mal eine riskante entscheidung
getroffen die er dann später bereut habt
schreibt mir das gern mal in die
kommentare analysiert mal euer eigenes
verhalten bin schon sehr gespannt was
dabei herumkommt wie man vielen dank
fürs zuschauen und bleibt neugierig bis
zum nächsten mal